[Music]
we have a clip here and this is from the
new season anything we need to know yes
and this is very low concept episode
we're cut we're uh we're caught in a
pyramid scheme and we've made a really
bad video and we're trying to sell a
retired wrestler played by Roddy Piper
on our gettin sucked into our pyramid
scheme let's thing with this does the
sophisticated business model of
invigaron confuse you you need to
understand how and vigorón works because
somebody above you does so ask less
questions and make more money
[Music]
still not convinced
well guess what the invigaron system is
also a pyramid scheme pyramid scheme you
ask I basically a house of cards where
the at the bottoms wall work
and give all the money to the smart guys
up at the top all right now we can don't
just be successful be very seriously so
much so do
there we go all right any questions